[Music]
welcome to another exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals or absolute trash now
here are your hosts Kevin Ryan and H
Foley hey everybody out there and
welcome back to everybody's favorite new
podcast it's ru garbage I am your host H
Foley sitting here and to my immediate
right is my good pal my co-host the
[ __ ] brains behind the operation gang
all right
he's not only a client he's also the
owner Kevin James Ryan everybody doesn't
make any sense but happy to be here
thanks for tuning in everybody real
quick just to shout out to everybody
that just left five star reviews all
right keep them five stars coming yeah
this week we got Big Gay and spuds
McGillicuddy Kim sue baseball freak else
told Sully fail Bundy FMS BK Nora Lenny
scrubs j MF slap yo pappy court can't
win and gutter sleuth thank you very
much we appreciate it
keep them coming yeah guys please keep
them coming subscribe to subscribe to us
on the youtube page subscribe to us on
iTunes and anywhere you guys listen to
your hot pods we are out there and
available whether you got a [ __ ]
Android and iPhone [ __ ] singular
sprint whatever garbage [ __ ] service
carrier you got we'll be there
okay and boys girls I gotta say we've
had some guests in the past okay but
this kid right here is a [ __ ] get
next to the coronavirus itself
you can't get any [ __ ] bigger all
right this guy has what not one but two
amazing [ __ ] hugely popular podcasts
he's got the you up podcast on betches
and he's got the original the og the
[ __ ] Jay Train podcast he performs at
clubs all over the [ __ ] country and
just so you guys know
March 19th to the 21st he's gonna be at
laughs Boston in Boston Massachusetts
then he comes back to [ __ ] NYC April
17th through the 18th at Gotham comedy
club ladies and gentlemen word on the
street is he got a pretty nice piece on
him - Jared freed everybody it's a
strong
medium whoa thank you meet quarterly
Irvine yeah yeah I'm not impressing that
so much not gentle
don't have to work no I'm showing up to
work everybody that's right no issues
here good to be here thank you for that
intro bunny thank you man you know uncle
you know I'm a big fan all right I know
I'm a big thing I'm a fan of yours thank
you buddy
I like you I like watching you onstage
you're so funny
thank you it's good to be here with you
thank you big fans you both so I'm happy
how many episodes are we in yet where is
this 5 episode 5 yeah I am really very
um I feel I'm you know I feel nice it's
nice you're number 3 we're bumping you
we're dropping you Monday oh my god I
know we're going in for the spring you
are definitely by far especially in like
my group of friends or people that I
know you're a comedian 99% of the time
it's do you know Jared free oh hey train
and or Schulz schultzy but it's usually
you're the goat do you know a lot of
Jews I know a lot of Jews and a lot of
bro so that's right away that's my
wheelhouse young professionals with a
little bit of cash in their thirties who
are about to settle down I just want
everybody I last kiss all right but this
is like [ __ ] Superman walking in on
my best I was at a show I was hosted at
New York Comedy Club before she maybe
like a month ago and I look up and there
is a [ __ ] 10 I mean a 10 a New York
City 10 going hey I thought you really
funny you're buddies with Jared freed
aren't you and my hat was on this
podcast she's again it's very early on
[Music]
please hug my place Please Please Touch
Me hey get over here you
like I can take it one more time woman
just a compliment infolet yeah just to
go one step further
all right now I'm garbage but I spent a
lot of time in the in the fine dining
okay profession okay so I'm big on you
know the right way to do this the right
way to do that all that kind of stuff
right and the wrong yeah one of the
things that Jarrett does that I think is
so [ __ ] funny and I think there's a
[ __ ] show there okay is use [ __ ]
peoples who charcuterie board that's
right because that's the thing man
you're you're at that perfect age okay
then you you definitely have a high
income demographic alright yep Seinfeld
through those first [ __ ] [ __ ]
episodes that he put on make sound
[ __ ] Lowenbrau and [ __ ] BMWs he
would have been at the [ __ ] yeah we're
bringing this is this is a fair point
yes so you had a new habit I've also
always you know I've never really this
is who I am I come I know I'm not one of
the unbelievable things was this this
like when I first started doing stand-up
was like ever like I would go up and
talk about like going on dates and it
was like a lot like as if I was going up
in the screaming racial slur yeah you
look so annoyed what's wrong with these
paper I was like the girls yeah like
what you guys don't have any connection
to this at all like you can't see anyone
connecting with us you get your lacrosse
stick stuck in your head right and the
girl you likes on the sideline yeah like
I but I understand like that is not
related to rock those broken back yeah I
would but I always gave the other side
the benefit of the doubt like I'd hear
someone go up and be like and to talk
about how like you know I'm like a DC
movie ruin their life and I'd like okay
I can
I understand where you're coming yeah
like that's not my perspective but I get
it and there was never I don't maybe
because like I'm so mayn't like my
perspective has been on TV forever on in
entertainment forever that it was like
we've had enough yeah but apparently not
because [ __ ] the numbers don't lie
baby the silent majority obj the
opposite of the personality of a lot of
like beginning comedian dude there was
someone that went on stage less I did a
show last night and the guy who's put it
together like he's a normal nice guy
funny uh-huh and then he for whatever
reason this was his show but he was like
it was his big anniversary show and then
he would bring up this like guy who
wasn't a comic but he was like
interviewing him I don't know if this is
very confusing but okay I'm I'm on Bora
basically this guy with a huge Gandalf
looking beard and like he's like this
like you know that like older younger
hipster like they have like young face
like look like they've never dealt with
the stresses of life but they've aged or
old they're all from money they probably
sold a lot of weed and [ __ ] college
yes still dressing like they're 14 but
they're a so this guy was like
interviewing the host of the show but he
goes and he was trying to do like a bit
and the bit was like basically asking
the host the show so like about
comedians he goes so they say that
comedians are and then he goes through
this horrific list of characteristics
yeah he goes he goes [ __ ] depressed
narcissist and and he goes to like 10
negative negative things and I was like
and then he's like what's up with you
you know what's your problem to the host
and I was sitting in the back just like
seething yeah I'm like you just want
people to be as miserable as you and you
didn't even take the chance to do stand
you know like you're putting your [ __ ]
on other people please tell me you're
terrible as well yeah yeah he's like so
you know so you know now that I know
your darkness and it's like I knew what
I was about to go up and talk about the
bachelor for like this guy's gonna hate
me like so pimple popper yeah but I do
love a chick you to reboard i I'm a hue
like
here's a funny dude yeah thank you but
here's the thing this is this is the
interesting part it's not like he's
going out and looking for him they're
[ __ ] said they're knocking on his
door that's where the [ __ ] I'm
getting a hundred a weekend so funny
that's where the thing and I had this
idea for this thing you know as a matter
because it's locked in here just in case
anybody tries to get smart and get some
[ __ ] bozo to do okay but if you went
to people's parties like like people
that like in their 30s they just got
married they bought a home yeah they
have like that [ __ ] you know that
housewarming party that Super Bowl party
or that thing in the summer yeah if you
went and critique how the what what the
spread was like are the beers warm I'd
like to live laugh love thing but I I
I'm trying you know I take I consider
all of my social media to be incubators
for things that could be like larger
ideas yeah no everything only started
cuz I tweeted out the tweet was I can
tell what type of parent you'll be -
based on your territory then I go and
then it was fine like a 12:30 in the
morning tweet I thought nothing of the
next day I was going my girlfriend on
vacation and all these people responding
to tweet so what kind of parent would I
be what can I be would I be and I didn't
know that all these women have pictures
of the boards that they made in their
course so as you know do they want to
look cool that they want they read
[ __ ] Martha Stewart absolument garden
they want their [ __ ] house to look
like that
so the point of the whole review of them
is to say is that thing where it's like
you're creating a meal for people huh
I'm the hungry husband walking in yes
that's every review of mine is through
the blends of the hungry husband is all
you got yeah this is what your [ __ ]
boy Kennedy driveway yeah you told me
not to eat dinner yeah and this is what
they [ __ ] what this is what am I
supposed to expect next
you know if this is the end the
beginning what's the end gonna be you
know again and I'm Li never getting off
the ground this is the the but with
charcuterie boards to me are the perfect
metaphor for Instagram versus reality
what does fulfill versus what is fulfill
you know what-what is junk food versus
filling what is there never again I
noticed of the people that have
submitted to you
they never skimp so it's never like I
wouldn't eat that no but it's just like
we're being [ __ ] you know what they
want the line Ramsay critiquing of this
alright yes you know they're Apes not on
the vine [ __ ] black olives out of the
cab so yeah and it's like what's right
you're looking for what's wrong the
multicolored cheese what this is what
I'm saying this is hoping I can cope I'm
with you man and it bothers me to my
core um cuz I look at some of these and
I go and I'm offended for the guy there
who is hungry
so of course and I mean the thing is you
did you make this for likes or did you
make this for actual fulfillment fill
someone stop satisfied satisfied when I
see an acorn on the board that acorn is
a symbol of narcissus of you not of you
not caring what me the view caring about
yourself I remember going to a wedding
once okay I go to this wedding and
there's one bar okay one bar and
everyone's lined up at this bar and
they're all hot as [ __ ] and there's no
AC it's an outdoor wedding God and and
then I see the the groomsmen and the
groom's the groomsmen and the groom are
all in matching suits and I said to one
of the guys I go how what's the matching
suits he goes oh this we all got
specially made suits suits suits like
suits like suit suits like like we got
hand-stitched specially and he's showing
me the initials and he's like and and
the groom paid you know for it and that
was his gift to the groomsmen I was like
I was like so seven of you got suits
instead of another bar there is no
brand-new suit I mean this is what I'm
talking about this is what people people
it's okay to kind of look beyond is that
there's a pie chart' everything there's
a finite amount of resources for
everything we do we have only so many
hours in the day you only have so many
so many so much
inches on the charcuterie board of life
and I'll say this in defense I see I
think that's a garbage move in some ways
but then I also say if your real garbage
okay if you're if you're like you know
from a working-class environment you're
gonna put the money into that extra bar
and not the [ __ ] so that's it but to
me that's it's garbage perspective you
know you one person's garbage is another
person's treasure one of those moments
where it's like you know you it's all
about perspective because I like killing
for the free suits my dad got an
interview Monday my dad when he goes to
a restaurant he'll go I'm like we went
to a new restaurant and I was like and
he goes his one review of the restaurant
was I don't know if I get a burger I
want the burger coming off the place
yeah that was his only review he goes
it's a small but I want to come on up I
go but how did the burger taste he goes
it wasn't coming off the plate doesn't
matter we're talking about two different
things yeah yeah you what do you mean he
wants it he wants the burger so big that
he has to bring some home and he has
breakfast tomorrow
he is thinking he doesn't care about the
like a raccoon not a person give me
portions I don't I don't want I one by
one it as big as my dad no he loves it
my dad my dad's like would rather go to
Maggiano's her like a family-style meal
you go to like what Carbone and get like
a tasting thing from the chef I got you
that's what it's all about that it's
value it's right it's where do you place
your values and that's what a turkey
rewards that's garbage a little bit I
like is then the garbage mentality like
to me to him and to me when I review
these boards I think you're a garbage
person for putting an angry acorn on
because you're all you're not yeah look
you're being a dick yeah you're doing
that for you that's that's that self
that was for for you and your Instagram
profile he's gonna eat the [ __ ] acorn
lady oh I always want to eat this no I
want to eat the Acorn
I want to choke on the a corner and go
this is cuz of you like I want to look I
want to be holding my throat going I
told you my cards like I I've eaten the
garnish before and gotten people got
really mad at me yeah dinner parties
what are you doing a girlfriends like
you're embarrassing me they do the
closed mouth
you're embarrassing me that's like
around the holidays all these
poinsettias dude I just good point
enough with the poinsettias yeah yeah
I'm a couple cheez-its in here we I'm
starving I made a board a couple of
weeks ago I had Pete did your making
boards I didn't take it I was so you
worse I swear to god do i bei was
trending the night before I started
making it he he was in my thumb inhale I
can tell him girl went out and bought
everything and then I knew I wasn't have
to make it the next day it was for me
Ritz or Mac when we got married no and I
was like I had opened up the thing I'm
like I was like this is what she bought
I'm like I'm gonna have to go out in the
morning and get more [ __ ] and I was I
didn't you making a board for people
yeah
no not for my staff for people yeah Hika
board for myself sometimes said he
didn't get invited
oh no he's that runs deep he's very
upset
get married and get the [ __ ] invite
oh my god yeah I had to pay two seats
it's different you know
in his defense he had a finite resource
city very finite resources it was for
visa purposes you know we might grab my
ladies from another country so a
situation similar yes it was very
run-and-gun you know what I mean
gotta get ready he loves the trashy TV
oh that's do I just sort of watching 90
day fiancé
with my lady and do you want what does
she think as someone who's coming from
another country 90 day fiancé
well it's pretty funny this week I had
the perspective change of like she
watches it and she's like oh I
understand this journey the journey
these girls are made course and I look
and I'm like oh I'm or man wait are they
all from another countries that the
whole deal the whole deal is hold on
yeah the show is so popular it's you now
it was like three spin off there's like
seven yeah it's crazy so now you don't
know which way is up and which way is
they have going there they have coming
here there before the 90 days after the
90 days it's a whole it's a lot of them
good job or ssin of them do yeah any
hotties what's the deal there's a couple
there's a couple that you're like that
well that's the thing they all have
their own separate storylines so like
some of the storylines are based in he
has money she's very young or it's based
in they don't speak in the same language
or they or it's based in that you know
the sheet you know that he wants to be
some
thing here you know like they all it's
not it's not toes it doesn't slam one
gender it doesn't at all it doesn't slam
one age group it's slim some people old
people race everything ever cross it's
every country it's really across all
Nigeria Columbia to [ __ ] pole into
it's literally [ __ ] all across the
world it's it's a great show and they're
also I used to think the batch or had
the best editors on TV I think we should
crushing it it's been like I'm a [ __ ]
crook cuz I look at the dudes and I just
relate to them I'm like I'm a [ __ ]
wacko just cuz I brought this girl over
from another country yeah she's like oh
my god these they're doing this journey
and I'm just like sitting there and they
just cut to the guy he's like balding
and soup out of a can I'm my god
it is nice that she's like look at their
journey and she's not like make like it
would be bad if you looked over and
she's like I can't believe she didn't
sign that paper white guy like oh she
played it wrong like like if she's
playing like Monday Morning Quarterback
how to [ __ ] over the guy my mother be
nice to the mother yeah how do you know
so much about visa stuff I want to get
into the game here play the game gang
this is why we're here this is our you
garbage it's everybody's [ __ ] brand
new favorite podcast okay so what's the
game what are we doing so what game is
we're gonna ask you a series of
questions my friend let me just tell the
listeners at home age Foley was like
come on the podcast and I go great and
then he nothing else was literally I
learned the name of this podcast and you
via Mike cannons episode and I go I
guess I'm garbage let's do this so I
don't know and I know as much as the
listener does oh yes I think you're nice
a you're not garbage and I say you're
the first one that isn't garbage because
we've all been garbage we have Mike and
he's trash yeah Donnelly of course not
only was under on the fence there we got
coming up Canadian garbage I don't think
he's garbage but he grew up right here
what this is the definition of garbage
so this is
is kind of its it does it's not based on
money okay because the name of magnet
now is we all just agreed he's garbage
even though just from knowing there's
some nice people that are can I don't
know garbage to me is like I'm Sadie and
you're a liar like garbage is a liar
[ __ ] it's behave it's made you're in
public it's not it's not poverty line
it's like okay like take your socks off
on the [ __ ] plane take your socks off
on the plane I know okay I do take my
shoes off if I'm in first class now the
only way I will only take my shoes off
if I'm in first class in a lie-down seat
that's the only way that's I think it's
appropriate for both I wouldn't shame I
also wouldn't shame someone for like the
passenger shaming Instagram account you
guys follow them I've seen I've been on
it yeah you gotta watch the girl who has
her feet on the screen and she's
flipping the channels with her that's
garb it's gone oh yeah say something
there if she was sitting next to you I
don't know that I think when I when I
when I follow passengers Jamie and I see
their pose I I do think more of them are
debatable than not yeah like I said I I
don't think that all of them are black
and white like that you know when you
see a foot in someone's earlier and
you're like yeah like that whole debate
of the guy with the woman the woman
reclined yeah that guy's a piece of [ __ ]
I think the guy's a piece of [ __ ]
because I wasn't like you know this that
lands in the life isn't fair category
you're in the last of the plane that
sucks but it's like he probably did
something and he probably got like two
Super Saver [ __ ] ticket that you're
gonna get to choose your seed and like
they put you there even beyond that this
chair allows for the woman recliner come
on okay it doesn't go back eight inches
it doesn't go back three inches it goes
back four okay that's the same with life
like sometimes it rains when you're
supposed to be outside all day yeah you
know like it sucks but I so I I don't
understand who's defending him and I
don't know what happened the other thing
is you don't know what happened before
like I don't
yeah I don't know it was a nice
conversation of saying hey it was I
think she put it back and he said hey do
you mind wait until I'm finished eating
and she did and then when he got done
she put it back and then I guess he
[ __ ] freaked out
the thing like he looks like a little
[ __ ] [ __ ] I just yeah I don't like
the idea of like yeah III and but it's
like these thing online is the land of
black and white that's why it's so much
fun sometimes but it's also why it's
gets kind of depress yeah exactly
there's nothing you know nothing's click
worthy about the gray area these people
had a disagreement about the seat yeah
but I I do have a lot of plain opinions
so yes well let's get down to the game
so i score is that what it is we garbage
you're not okay I like this well John
was leaning toward not carbs and he said
you're thinking about your dad with the
hamburger no isn't we you know good
value just just to just to get a little
idea here you grew up in what was a town
in Massachusetts outside of Boston
called Needham that's right also known
as Juden I've composed people do refer
to as Jew Tain's anti-semite still your
parents your parents were Dennis right
no I don't know are you looking at me
like I give you a faction on the [ __ ]
guy I don't know did you would you say
you grew up upper-middle class or a
little bit more I'll call it
upper-middle class I would say you know
we did know I pictured you guys growing
up like fifties rich you know like
families in the 50s they weren't like a
rich but they have like nice houses and
they all had made so you had a maid
didn't you you know we didn't we didn't
call the maid I wasn't like you know the
maids here like that we had help run
those maybe your land my landscapers
training Petrini ladies anything that's
pretty much it was a guy I think that
was like I think so company don't
correct me on the don't don't quote me
on that but I think that's it I can't
believe how quickly I pulled that out of
my ass but I was like he just wrote him
a check
yeah hit him Kippy Oh get him alright
have you ever put subwoofers in your car
no oh was that being a grown-up no also
not a big thing around where I was like
I remember one time growing up my friend
Aaron he put a like a tip remember that
video on you to the Whistler tip the
whistle tip was like I [ __ ] hate the
sound one of those cars drives by I want
to kill
my friend put one of those on his car in
high school and it was funny because if
I love it for the joke he thought it was
cool but then it went like it didn't it
didn't induce the reaction that you
thought it would it was so high-pitched
that it was actually hilarious but it
was so annoying to miss it was gonna be
a good idea that's great that maybe just
think of him and now gonna call but are
you familiar with a product known as
sunny delight of course drank it when
you were a kid never didn't like the
taste thought it was tangy
yeah totally bad in the back of the
throat I'm alive no don't know it just
straight orange juice orange juice
minimal pulp Wow Tropicana
we're like leveling pulps yeah we've got
orange juice with a little bit of all
Tropicana
I don't remember maybe sometimes we'd
get like the good stuff he's got cash I
was I was such a [ __ ] growing up I
remember my mom would buy Paul I'd meet
her would make her strain the pulp out
sometimes with ice it was really good
yeah I've ever had that a little little
tidbit for the coronavirus people out
there it's coming baby we could all be
dead next week all right have you ever
hung out on a couch in a garage no no
whoa classy that's upright we got no
theorems we got second living rooms
where I'm from that was that was big
that was because like where when we grew
up cuz there was like it was like a
place to go out and like sneak cigs and
drink that to me is like that 70s show
yeah second living room and waiting for
the main service charcuterie yeah my god
the second living room the second living
room was always like the TV room you
know they'd give it they didn't want to
call the second living room be like
that's the living room and then that's
the TV room you're like yeah you got to
[ __ ] living room a lot of kids I grew
up with caught up their parents caught
up the great room in the great the great
room yeah that's very we didn't have a
great that's very Gentile
that is we go to the great room after
first communion doesn't feel gee we had
the family room the living room we had
the living room and our kids gonna be
like we had the fallout shelter to
escape the fallout room the panic room
alright let's quit screwing around here
start playing [ __ ] hardball get him
buddy
alright freed here we go do you any
member of your family have a tattoo of
the drummer known as animal no tattoos
and my whole family except for one a
couple cousins but my one cousin when he
got a tattoo it was all in it sorry go
so it was a tribal armband because he
was of the age when that was like a that
was in the 90s you talk to him not
anymore
[Laughter]
is that because that religion a Jewish
thing religion or is it just class like
you Jewish tribal armband no to not oh
yeah no tattoos on the Jews I wasn't
sure how there won't bury in the
cemetery
well they say that's a myth I've never
looked into it enough my I had a
fleeting thought of getting a tattoo
once and then I was like you know what
I'm out I don't want that was I was one
of my questions a big woman we were
growing up the big thing was you're
getting your like initials in Old
English or something or like your last
name we were like there were certain
parts of my town that we read suburbs of
Boston the big thing is a I ran the
Fighting Irish guy that was that was big
for those are the people that I would
have to deal with across across the
street like on akuze and [ __ ] oh you're
Foley's in right yeah so obviously
nobody in your family any articles of
clothing tire covers or any kind of body
art with the individual known as the
Tasmanian devil
no Tasmanian devil we've learned into
Tazz our
all right I've seen this I understand I
understand where these questions are
coming you went a little I've watched
you know MTV Spring Break Daytona Beach
[Music]
yeah have you ever gone to a live
professional wrestling event yes many
many as a recent child Manny
pay-per-views I've been to every one
that came to Boston we would go my seats
were nicer than what you don't think
yeah yes i-i've fond memories of
Survivor Series and yeah I was a bit my
family my brother my dad and I loved
wrestling could you make posters no
posters but we were we were dad - my dad
loves wrestling so we would growing up
my dad would receive this is actually
crazy
there was this wrestling newsletter
before the Internet
yeah that you could get like on the side
the image of your dad like running out
for the mailbox they get it hold on it
gets worse we growing up he my dad's
would get this magazine that would give
you inside wrestling like like stuff you
find out on the Internet like it was a
chatroom [ __ ] for sure for the Internet
but he would get it he didn't want to
pay for it so he would so my dad's best
friend from growing up used to read it
first then send it to us and then can
you imagine that's [ __ ] trap but now
but like now like can you imagine like
putting something in the mail for your
friend on a monthly basis you don't even
put things in the mitt you don't even
put your bills not else on my suit I
don't mail things that I'm supposed to
mail Google any way around it I'm going
I don't know this guy was going to back
my families and it would sit in our
toilet until the next month yeah that's
[ __ ] wild it's pretty crazy
yeah all right I'm gonna ask you a
series of questions about one okay now
did you ever own or have a collection of
the following items all right now please
note that all collections must be
answered no to not be considered garbage
yes and I'm saying
nose across the board nose across the
board nope okay collection ready or any
of these items ever in your house swords
of any kind no nunchucks no yo-yos no
Chinese stars no never have a Chinese
star growing up now not even thought of
what I know you did scumbag no no what's
a couple of martial artists between
friends no Asian fighting paraphernalia
in a barrel chopsticks what about him as
so far did you think he was gonna answer
yes to any of them Chinese star I
thought I would just hang in there
alright dude I
what about beanie babies yes oh that's
well your that's an investment that was
the financial this is all like hinging
on unjú enos like like I flinch on the
subway when the dancers come through
like I'm mad too so like I like the
beanie babies like my grandmother was in
love my grandmother was like down with
the beanie
are they still floating around the
family at all are they an amazement she
was so in and then the McDonald's beanie
babies were like a huge deal my
grandmother was like in on that I knew
the Chinese knockoff beanie boo that was
a big deal are you [ __ ] with me
please tell me your beanie boos beanie
boos I ever played darts before yeah
trash lawn darts I think the outlaw dad
they vowed they outlaw that like ditch
one he's dude what do you thought those
are the ones you like flip up and then
they like they were gone when I was a
kid but there would always be like one
in the back of a rusty one ya know I
never had those and he ever pick any of
the following bellybutton have I picked
my bellybutton yeah yeah yeah nose 10
minutes ago
butthole yes of course what feels better
than that man just end up a little then
you get in there and a little fingernail
that's a little too long a butthole a
little too wet is there anything
I mean that's vacation that is that's
far from garbage buddy that huh right
there baby that's an extra 10 minutes in
the shower like I don't know if this is
wrong all right a little different when
you say it okay I can't hear about your
things I can't draw the line you heard
of exfoliant now you know the dogs
feeling when he's licking his balls he's
probably in paradise yeah I just goes
back to travel have you ever bought food
in the terminal taking it on the plane
and eating it there
no like I mean against this you can't be
bringing like a burger something here's
my test smell here's my here's my snack
later I also want to know what you
travel I want to know I what I say is
you are allowed to bring anything on the
flight that doesn't stick to the wall
perfect so if I can take your preflight
snack and throw it against the wall and
it doesn't stick you're on the plane
your deck ma peanuts
whatever but if I take a burger but yeah
but if you come in with a pulled pork
sandwich and I stick against the wall
people are [ __ ] do it
people are [ __ ] people are doing it I
don't do it it's just it's it's just not
right I think that's worse than the
shoes off thing with socks on oh no I
think it's especially since I it's the
shoes off with socks it's like common
now especially if on a longer flight
it's very everybody's doing it thick new
sock yeah you're working good sauce sure
I'm all about it especially you know if
you're flying dude you're up or to LA or
whatever from New York I totally I'm on
board but I've seen people do no sigh
like take their socks off and it's so
one guy cut his [ __ ] toenails yeah on
a way to Europe that's crazy
I'm I think also a lot of this stuff
Edom is foreigners intermingling like
not you know like that might be socially
except
the flight to Europe like that makes
sense to me like
not to say plan to be like a like a like
a like a like a USA all the way from I
feel like we've had these conversations
amongst us yes I know that last night I
sat next to this date okay
there was a date next to me on that I
and I was like starving I didn't you
know were you went to a sushi place okay
and like West Village by yourself just
by myself arts class put headphones in
there by himself sushi always so I put
in some headphones but they seat me
right next to this date and I got a diet
coke and I'm like you know you're eating
by yourself with headphones on so you
just turn into a big fat [ __ ] animal
like I'm like you know huffing down
saying I don't hear anything
I'm just going and at one point like I
take a sushi and I put it down and I
take a sip of soda and like you have
that and I just go the and I burn and I
like and I like oh my and then like also
I find myself back in yeah and I check
back in and I look over and this is like
nice-looking couple next to me where
I've definitely ruined their day but
they were I was like I turned off the
podcast I was listening to like like
Jarrod [ __ ] quiet down you horse and
then I like listening to them and there
was a moment where I go maybe they don't
speak English and I was like in my mind
if they didn't speak English it would
have been better than fine alien vibe
but like a burp as a burp as a bird what
are we talking russian mandarin it's a
burp but i do think when you don't speak
the language of the people you're around
you think that there's some sort of like
that like like window like we have like
you're in a booth a little bit i think
you forget yeah yeah so it goes both
ways i'm saying you know foreign person
cutting the nails being like i think i
speak german who the [ __ ] knows i'm
clipping my toes in german yes so i
understand and also but it's like what
do you travel in each sweats g know i
have a very specific you travel a lot i
travel a good amount i have been
recently i'm lucky enough to do that so
i I go sneakers mm-hmm
Lululemon pants black t-shirt Lululemon
sweatshirt had Bose headphones I want to
lean all black lemon let's clean all
Lulu
I want wicking moistur technology
they're like sweatpants I do like the
joggers I don't want the ones that like
they have to cut at the ankle yeah and I
have to have zip pockets and I don't
want to like wear a belt like I want to
be so sleek that I never break stride
through TSA yeah dude you got to do it
rob a Lulu I mean it feels good what's a
pair of slacks at Lululemon Sonya I have
two pairs of them it's not like I have a
buzz you need the zip that's that's a
problem I have a back pocket zips out
the front that is open for my phone so
the back pocket I can put like an ID zip
it up great walk right through
I also Lululemon underwear Sunny Delight
yeah this he's got Lulu underwear I was
inside I was insulted by the question
but I didn't bring up so you ever have a
Hawaiian pizza no see a Hawaiian pizza
feels like what people have when they
like imagined Hawaii yeah oh yeah like
it wasn't like the people are like Oh
[ __ ] can we put up like some guy in
Brooklyn it's a sunny day on top from
one of the from one of the dumpsters
calling the fans dumpster just made that
one up if you guys are an SNL parody of
a podcast just yeah it's so funny
because I didn't know I don't know
medicine Ella's done this bit but like
two guys starting a podcast an episode
one be like subscribe on YouTube
subscribe rate review subscribe come on
you gotta you got to give me those five
stars you haven't even started the show
yet he's like no no the dumpsters I
gotta hear from the dumpsters and then
like get on the patreon the patrons
$5.99 a month you're gonna get an extra
episode of the garbage time every day
every day every day I love what you're
doing I love that you came out we're
doing it's right I think you are I know
I'm agreeing with it but it's so funny
like all of these things in Grain like
we all know the thing yeah so look I
remember when I started you up like I
knew how I was like I know
how to direct this you know this large
cruise ship I know that we need people
to make it their Instagram stories which
you should ask people their Instagram
stories that they're listening here you
heard j-train story so I but I knew when
I spoke you know like when I fire
j-train started like eight seven eight
years ago now so like now I look back
I'm like man if I could get that
restarted I'd be up on the charts that
see me you know like I understand but it
was fun it's funny that like when I
started you up we were like okay like I
remember like Jordana who's the co-host
she was like I was like we got to get
him rate review yeah I knew all the
pieces but it's like cuz we're all
comics so we all know people with
podcast yes I want yeah if you're
outside of this world like it's like
when someone's like oh you're putting up
stand up on Instagram it's like yeah we
follow I follow Romanians yeah yeah so
it's like everyone's doing the one
person that one person that follows you
is gonna go this is the best ever I get
free comedy you know
yeah we've also heard 15,000 communities
like rate review subscribe so as I said
this is from one of the dumpsters do is
10% to corner I'm gonna tell you Foley
is onto something these are great merch
yeah okay just the dumpster sell
waistband we can sell waste baskets and
stuff you know it's pretty good yeah
okay I want a different direction that's
okay trash liners by heavy bag health
powder this is my buddy Brian down
ashore okay I knew it yeah you know he
wasn't from Avalon garbage yeah how do
you know down there I did a summer in
Avalon because I want to Penn State
everyone like a bunch of guys my house
we all got a house after I graduate the
summer after I graduated we got a house
down in Avalon and like beacon a which
[ __ ] lost control the Princeton the
white briar
I used to call the Princeton the lazy
river because all you do it's so big
that you just kept watching and then the
white briar had the sushi yeah
no shower happy hour yeah yeah there my
Penn State complete garbage
there's the garbage element up everybody
110,000 and maybe next and final quote I
think it's Brian's questions ever had a
party ball yes party yeah yeah I think
those they were they phased out though
they that's a great idea
party ball is a very generational thing
like we had those there was a it was
like the keg that was a ball yeah
disposable cake totally we had it in the
woods that was like a high school
definitely would you drink in college
Baca soda we're the cars and we used to
go out with like oh yeah well we did
natty light of course but like to keep
you know the cheap beer remember when
Red Bull vodkas hit oh that was they
were taking people I don't left and call
them bone sauce those early days it de
Ravin that's all well it's a Red Bull
vodka like when you start to think about
it you're like man what a dumb concept
an upper and a lower and the same [ __ ]
dream just anyway you were drinking when
you were 22 or 20 or whatever and just
like no-holds-barred [ __ ] you
that was before the sugar free yeah
remember them people and then you get
these guys that were like no make sure
that the sugar free it's like are they
insane
that'll really slowly yeah get the [ __ ]
out of here alright I got I got one more
and that's it I have which I think
you've probably answered with the pack
forgot you went to meditate have you
ever tailgated a sporting event with no
intention of going into the game I went
to four games in my four years of Penn
State really before yeah I was the
tailgate czar for my fraternity to pass
down position
so I mean King of Kings so I yeah I we
would my fraternity was known for its
tailgate when it when it was one
fraternity it was Beta Theta Pi which if
you google right now there's been very
tragic news other than the fraternity
reason recent events so it's like it's
one of those things it's like it's it's
funny what it's not funny but it's like
with anything College the more you
Google the worst of wolves yeah don't
Google Penn State you'll find some bad
stuff
don't Google beta there hi you'll find
some bad stuff but when I was there you
know this was kind of when you know what
my group that my generation we all were
nice guys and everyone to be successful
yeah fun and cool all that stuff but we
used to have a tailgate where we would
basically like four hundred people would
show up so I would this tailgate jar was
a passed down position every year two
guys would have it and we would Friday
we'd go to like the the market and get
like three types of chicken steak tips
pork loin chips doing it right you get a
pallet of beer yeah everything you go to
the beer store gonna and then throught
Saturday morning we were up at like 6:00
a.m. like hot week all the pots and pans
go around the house with pots pans and
ring um some people would wake up yeah
we know who we go to the field and like
the pledges would help us and you get
out there we had this place called lot D
25 which was like a very like specific
area where we'd set up a grill that was
about the size of this table so it was
like a you know like a six foot yeah it
was it was a made furred event yeah not
just wasn't like for your deck so we'd
have the grill the going this way and
then a table creating an L and that
would be like the outer perimeter of our
party and then going back it was just a
field and then the woods kind of like
cupped us off so we had like a little
femme
natural barriers I like zactly so that
Egypt what what happened was when we
first were doing it we do it at the
tailgate feel Penn State is built for
tailgating yeah yeah yeah it's the
stadium surrounded by just fields and
fields and field so it's built in a way
that not a lot of schools are built
especially land wise so we used to be in
the part of the tailgate fields where it
was car car car car car so we would be
kind of on top of other people we've
gotten so much we'd have so much issues
with like someone throwing someone a
beer and then it would hit on an old guy
in the head like it was like that type
of [ __ ] where it's like and then like
don't laugh at that but that's ya know
like a dad being like walking away
bleeding me like boys will be boys like
I'm at a tailgate sure who cares but we
were like we'd had enough of those
accidents that someone's like it was
funny it was as if it was like Lois and
Clark yeah they were like I found better
pastures just some land oh they saw
exactly walk over the hill and keep
going so we made a big change one year
to this lot D 25 where it had this like
natural land barriers and we get there
like 6:00 a.m. and I would go up to cars
as they because then you'd have those
people like work in the parking lot like
park they're parked there so as the
people would tell him to park near us I
would go up to them kind of with like a
crowd control and just be like hey I'm
just gonna let you know we're gonna get
a little wild over here there's a lot of
people you guys we have food we got
beers we got breakfast burritos if
you're here early we'd make breakfast
people would do this way for free yeah
with the fraternity would pay for it and
then we just invite everyone when I
started doing it I started taking money
from other like I started being like hey
lacrosse house if you want to come throw
us this much and then you're all free to
come we're not gonna like stamp tickets
at the door but like you are you're
contributing just as a team we'll have
it set up we just want your money to get
it up so we have so we would have this
huge thing and then girls you just want
girls to come so we'd set this up all
college ever Oh College I do there's
girls are coming exactly to tell party
girls are coming it's all just about
girls but tailgate was so known like so
regular that people would like sleep at
a girl's dorm room and then they
wouldn't even go home they go straight
to the tailgate and they'd be like
there's breakfast there wait so it was a
very nice thing you just see a guy
limping over the horizon toward you
bears
yeah exactly so then so cars will come
over and I go hey listen we have beer we
have vodka we have all this food you're
more than welcome to have any of it if
you want please but understand that
there's gonna be like a lot of people
here that you might not want to be
around sure you're free to go I would
just move your car now or pull up a seat
and have a great time but know that
you've been warned and you're gonna
catch your beard yeah you're gonna chop
them we're throwing beers and we're
we're lost and I'm this our own beers
today that's right so most the time 90%
the time they go thank you
their car and drive the [ __ ] away then
there'll be the 10% they were like we
have people that were like coming back
like repeat yes like all we're the best
time yeah so yeah so we do the tailgate
every week and my job was more tailgate
than it was football so you know that's
so I never really went to games wow
that's great
long story short Jarrod garbage thank
you harder percent I don't know about a
hundred percent your dad from what your
dad is for sure more than you Lululemon
underwear that's [ __ ] pretty nice
class yeah I'm sorry she by himself
what's your sushi order real quick what
do you get I like when they do something
special but I don't like too much of
like the May I don't like too much
American on mice I'm a simple guy like
the - yeah I like a salmon simple salmon
roll with like not a roll like as I like
with the salmon on top any guy I like a
sashimi
I like Elin avocado roll is always a
favorite of mine a dragon roll you're
making him sick you know the type yeah
no fun
all right so Jarek one more time you're
gonna be at laughs Boston March 18th
through the 19th or 19th to the 21st
March 19th through the 21st is laughs
Boston and then I'm gonna be in I'm
gonna be in Philly oh you got Philly
people right yeah soon I'll be in Philly
in June on your lunch line so I'll be
there in June I hope the link is out and
I'll be at Gotham April 17th and 18th so
if you
come come on out Jared free calm yeah
that's where I do awesome check it out
Kippy what do you got
everything's just kevin ryan comedy on
all social media Cameron comedy calm for
dates I got a bunch of Connecticut dates
coming up Jersey pa check it out
and yes rate review subscribe tell a
friend just like hippy said rate review
subscribe tell a friend we need it
alright follow us I'll we got the
Instagram is that are you garbage that's
right are you garbage H Foley on ice on
Twitter and Foley grams on Instagram
give us a follow and take charge arts
tip what do they have to do they have
two stories all they gonna do is screen
shines at their listed a screen hosted
as their story
o 200 people will see it passively they
all want to look and tag both of you
guys you guys will send on my heart post
it yeah alright we love you guys see you
guys thanks thank you